hi everyone my name is brianna frank and
i'm with the ibm cloud team
let's talk about ibm cloud satellite
today many enterprises are benefiting
from using public cloud to build
and run their applications being able to
consume
i.t as a service through apis at scale
and as needed has transformed how
applications are built
public cloud enabled companies to
innovate in new
faster ways but the reality is only
somewhere between
five and twenty percent of enterprise
workloads have moved to the cloud
that first wave of applications were
focused mostly on new workloads or
workloads that can easily relocate
many applications have requirements
around security
compliance latency regulation
and performance that mean those
workloads can't easily move
into a public cloud enterprises need an
ability to gain the benefits of public
cloud
anywhere they need their application to
run
what would help these enterprises is
something called distributed cloud
distributed cloud is a new cloud
computing model that extends public
cloud services to any location
this means companies can now run not
only in their primary cloud providers
infrastructure
but on premises in other cloud providers
in third party data centers or
co-location centers
or even at the edge in factories
distribution centers stores
hospitals and ports with everything
managed from one
single control plane ibm cloud satellite
is our new distributed cloud capability
with satellite you can take advantage of
the catalog of services from ibm cloud
with industry optimized security
and compliance and leading ai
capabilities
anywhere you need it all with a common
api
user experience management dashboard and
user consumption model
to see how ibm cloud satellite works
let's take a look at a couple of real
world examples
we'll start with the financial services
industry
on the surface the financial services
industry might seem like it's
all about money but it's really all
about technology
in order to compete financial
institutions need to create exceptional
user experiences
to do that they leverage ai and trading
algorithms
to stay ahead of the market to be
competitive
financial services clients need to
iterate quickly and leverage
cloud-native tools and best practices
however the financial industry is
heavily regulated
so they need to be able to keep that
data secure and compliant
which often means there are restrictions
on where that data can live
ibm cloud satellite can help solve this
conflict these financial services
companies can now extend public cloud
services
in their data centers allowing them to
leverage cloud native best practices
and meet their security and compliance
obligations all at the same time
so satellite enables you to take
advantage of a public cloud consumption
model
but in many different locations and you
don't have to be an expert in running
these software stacks
to run them outside of the public cloud
let's take a look at another example
this time in the construction industry
where worker safety is key
one of our clients is leveraging
distributed analytics to keep workers
safe
in this scenario you might have a
business or an office building that is
under construction
and you need to be able to leverage
video analytics to tell if someone is
wearing a hard hat or not
and warn them before they move into a
potentially dangerous area of that
building
they want to use video analytics to
automatically detect the situation
but latency could be a real problem if
you warn someone too late they could
possibly be injured
so let's take a look at how this
scenario might work
to solve the safety problem you need to
be able to analyze video data from many
cameras all over the office building
but it's impractical to send all that
data back to the cloud to be processed
remotely it would be better if the video
processing happened close to the actual
device
traditionally that would require you to
install servers and software
and manage them on-prem with ibm cloud
satellite we can extend the public cloud
into the office
so we can leverage cloud services to run
this application close to the device
and that's critical in ensuring that we
can reduce latency and effectively warn
someone
before they enter a dangerous area
that same client in this worker safety
scenario had to adjust to challenges
brought by the covent pandemic they were
able to quickly
iterate on their application and modify
the use case
now instead of warning workers about
wearing hard hats
they can make sure the workers are
wearing masks and ensuring the masks are
being worn correctly
they can even leverage thermal devices
to take temperatures
with ibm cloud satellite you can quickly
address unforeseen challenges
leverage cloud benefits in any location
and innovate quickly
anytime anywhere thank you for watching
if you have questions please drop us a
line below if you want to see more
videos like this in the future
please like and subscribe